in our journey studying evolution and
natural selection
we often index on individual organisms
if we look at a species or population of
a certain species
we've talked about how there could be
variation
in that population which i will depict
by these colors and
these shapes over here and sometimes the
variation
really doesn't confer any advantage or
disadvantage for
reproduction but sometimes it might and
if a certain variation maybe because the
environment changed or maybe the this
population finds themselves in a new
ecosystem
confers an advantage well that variant
will be more
likely to multiply and the genes which
produce
that phenotype are more likely to become
a larger and larger
part of the gene pool similarly if
there's some disadvantage maybe because
the
environment has changed some way well
that might select out
certain variants and the underlying
genetics that cause it
but this is when we're thinking about
traits that primarily affect an
individual's
chances of survival and reproduction but
we're going to do in this video as this
title implies
is focus on it's not just about
individual traits
there is also evolution of group
behavior
and we see that right over here in a
school of fish why does it make sense
for
these fish to ball up into this huge
school
it might seem like it makes it very easy
for a predator
to just go right into the middle of that
and open its mouth
and get as much as it wants an
all-you-can-eat buffet so to speak
well it turns out that this type of
behavior does
confer a benefit the benefit is yes this
shark that i just drew might be able to
get a mouthful of fish
but the great majority of the fish are
going to be protected
and by being in a big ball like this
instead of just having your own eyes
looking for a predator
as soon as any one of these tens of
thousands or maybe hundreds of thousands
of fish spot a predator
well the whole school will know it so
they're able to share
information also even though some fish
might get eaten up the probability that
anyone will be eaten by this
shark is actually lower versus if there
was just one of these
fish just swimming by itself that one is
much more likely to be picked off
and we see this type of behavior in many
many many types of animals
this right over here is a herd of
wildebeest and once again
if you have an individual wildebeest it
would be easy to be surrounded by say
hyenas by
predators they could be caught by
surprise the younger
of the wildebeest would be easy to pick
off if they were by themselves
but if they're in a herd maybe they can
be in the middle of the herd
here's an example of adult elephants
protecting their young
when they see a threat approaching and
notice more than just the parents are
protecting the young
these elephants are probably related to
each other and so even though one
elephant might sacrifice themselves
maybe from some type of a threat
if they're able to protect the young
even though it might not be their
child it might be their nephew it might
be their cousin their shared genetics
are more likely to be passed on you've
sometimes heard people say things like
i'd be willing to die for two brothers
or eight cousins
and that would actually make sense from
a genetic point of view
but it's not just about protection where
we see the evolution of group behavior
we could also see it in terms of
predation so this right over here is a
pack of wolves
that are attacking this bison here and
first of all you can see
how much more vulnerable this bison is
when it's alone than if it were part of
a herd
if it was part of a herd it would be
much harder to surround it you would
have a ton of these other bison all
around that could
run and chase individual wolves but when
this bison is surrounded like this when
it's outnumbered it is more vulnerable
and these wolves which are much much
smaller individually than this bison
have a decent chance of taking it down
so once again this group behavior of
these wolves to not hunt by themselves
but to hunt together
to surround animals to coordinate with
each other that allows them to prey on
animals
much much larger than themselves so i
encourage you to
think about this idea because it's
happening all around us
including in human beings we are social
animals
this is occurring throughout the animal
kingdom and it's a really fascinating
thing to observe
all around you